now my next guest has arguably done more
for women caught in the justice system
than anyone else in the UK
Harriet wistar it recently represented
Sally Challen who was released from jail
after 9 years for killing her husband
when the court ruled she had been a
victim of coercive control but
statistics released in the last few days
seem to suggest things may be going
backwards the number of convictions for
rape has fallen to a 10-year low that's
despite a record number of complaints
last year of the almost 58,000 reported
rapes there were just 1925 convictions
that means just 3 point 3 percent of
reported rapes end in a conviction at
the same time it's been revealed that a
number of people killed by their partner
has hit a five-year high with 173 people
killed in England and Wales last year 32
more than the previous year and Harriet
is with us now and Harriet just just
start with those figures I mean the rape
conviction numbers going down
that's quite alarming isn't it it's very
yes they're going down at a time where
women are coming forward more to report
rape particularly following their me to
movement so there is an increase in
reports but there is a very dramatic
decline in the number of prosecutions
we're actually bringing a legal
challenge which will be launching this
week against the Director of Public
Prosecutions because we believe that
this has come about as a result of a
change in the approach of the CPS
towards charge distribution service
towards charging decisions we think that
they are taking becoming more cautious
in an in an attempt to increase their
conviction rate and we've gathered a
whole range of evidence to support our
approach our challenge because at the
moment the Crown Prosecution Service are
denying what we say but
we have quite a lot of evidence to show
that that actually it's come right from
a cultural change at the top so the CPS
you're saying is in some ways raising
the bar when it comes to going for a
prosecution yeah okay yes and and and
and essentially there is a an approach
to prosecuting rape as we know rape is
kind of full of myths and stereotypes
because of the way our culture
understands sexual relationships and for
sex and so a few years ago the Crown
Prosecution Service introduced something
called the merits based approach to
prosecuting rape so the idea was to try
and have an approach to making decisions
when you look at the evidence and you
you look at it objectively on the facts
and try and free yourself from
second-guessing what a jury might decide
because there are all sorts of jury type
myths you know that everyday people may
think well the woman didn't report it
straight away she didn't struggle she
was dressed provocatively she was
drinking too much all sorts of
presumptions made about a woman's
behavior that may make juries less
inclined to convict
even though objectively on the evidence
you seem very old-fashioned presumptions
well they are they are but they still
seem to be pervade our wider public
views around rape and sexual offences so
your Kate your your issue is not with
the police who it's with the Crown
Prosecution Service yes well we say it
started with the Crown Prosecution
Service the results of this slight
cultural shift at the top and it's it's
minor but it kind of has a butterfly
effect as it as it goes across others
involved in prosecution and
investigation is that the police have
been receiving getting this negative
approach from the cps so they're
referring less cases all the cps are
sending stuff back that the police refer
and saying you've got to do X Y and Zed
and and their response is is either well
they're just
not going to prosecute in these cases or
that that you know if they're if they're
not that bothered they just think well
we can drop this one because it's so
like giving us a load of extra work
we've been reporting recently on a
number of cases that were dropped or
appear to have been dropped because
whatsapp messages or text messages have
come to light reflecting an amicable
relationship at the yeah well this is a
that the Crown Prosecution Service will
say one of the other things they say is
that since we now use we have access to
data we need to download all all the let
the data available to pass that on to to
the defendant and that's a sort of
separate issue in a sense but what it
does mean is it increases the volume of
work that the police have to do in terms
of you know that that very point well
there was evidence they were in an
amicable relationship that in itself is
is a potential myth because because you
happen to have an amicable relationship
doesn't mean that you can't then be
raped and that the man turns against you
and that's one of the things that does
come up quite a lot so to your point you
are going to what take a leave make a
legal case against the Crown Prosecution
Service yeah yeah we're bringing with
these what to achieve what well to
reverse the you know to reverse their
change in approach and to make them
reintroduce the merits based approach
and on the issue of domestic violence
and the killings
can you see a reason why those numbers
should be going up in such a way i I
think one of the reasons I mean this is
another piece of work we've done at the
Center for Miss Justice is is perhaps
partly down to under resourcing of
police and under and the lack of
training or understanding about the sort
of warning signals for fatal homicide
these are even a whelmingly women
victims yes and many perpetrators not
exclusively clear not exclusively no not
at all but but certainly
the majority of domestic homicides are
women victims by male partners and and
the the there are all sorts of
protective measures that police can take
to intervene where there are domestic
violence incidents but our our work we
work very much with frontline women's
organizations across the country who do
work around domestic violence as well as
rape and and they report to us that the
police are not using many of the powers
that they're given or they're not
arresting on breach of normal nurse
station order and of course even even
what seems like a small failure could be
the failure that makes the difference in
in a faithful homicide you famously
acted for the perpetrator of domestic
violence
Sally Challen how significant was your
victory and my other question I think is
how many Sally challon's
are there still in prison who you think
should be you know should be out yeah
well first of all although obviously
killing is an extremely violent act it
was a very very and it was a it was a
very violent killing it was the only
violence that ever ever occurred from
her in the relationship she she was what
the whole basis of that appeal was a
around evidence that emerged that she
had been a victim of systematic coercive
controlling behavior so although the
final act was was hers the the the
lead-up to the act and over a 40 year
relationship was one in which she was
the victim of the coercive and
controlling relationship and and in fact
this is the the the other side of the
coin offed in those cases where women
kill men in relationships they they are
responding to a kind of relationship
where they've been the victim throughout
and they've taken they've been driven in
a sense to listen to this final awful
act if you like because because of what
they've been subjected to there are we
we are actually doing some research at
the moment about how many how many women
are in similar positions to that and and
and we we're aware of quite a number of
cases in fact there are a number of
others in the pipeline which we're
trying to we're looking at ways of
appealing convictions but but to get
them reduced from murder to man's
the cases would meet more properly be
manslaughter rather than murder
so it's not not that the woman's saying
they didn't do it they accept they did
it
sometimes self-defense is is the
appropriate defense the difficulty with
social defense such as in the Sally
challeng case you have to show that
there's there's a response to immediate
threat and and so while some of those
cases do fit that that description
others others do not so so really what
you're looking at partial defenses to
murder which mitigates the gravity of
the offense if you like do you think
I've just got a minute or so left do you
think that the government is taking
domestic abuse seriously enough well the
the government did introduce a domestic
abuse bill we don't know how don't know
what says it will he does but obviously
everything is kind of being put on the
back burner at the moment and there may
be a general election and who knows what
follows the domestic abuse bill is easy
is a step forward it's and it it has got
shortcomings to it so it doesn't it
doesn't deal with anything but the real
problem is that you can have as many
different policies and measures and laws
but unless they're actually enforced by
by the police and by the other criminal
justice agencies they're not very much
use and and what has to go hand in hand
with the legislation is the funding and
the support to ensure that the criminal
justice agencies can enact those laws
and and we find that they're not doing
so a lot of the time and I'm very
briefly topical subject teresa may
giving a knighthood to Geoffrey Boycott
what do you make of that well it's
pretty awful really given given the
history of what what was described by
the French courts I think wasn't
still denies he does here but it seems
like fairly compelling evidence from
what I know yeah okay Harriet with
Strich preciate your time thanks very
much to coming in thank you